we've been talked about Ukraine
repeatedly we understand there is no
evading this question but you know we
always talk either about Ukraine about
something related to Ukraine several
years ago we talked about the crisis in
Iraq crises in different other countries
we're talking about what has already
transpired but we never talked about why
it has happened but if you want to talk
about it which is evidently quite
important I should like to start with
this very issue why is there a crisis in
Ukraine I was quite confident that after
the bipolar system went into oblivion
after the collapse of the Soviet Union
certain Western partners of ours
particularly the United States were any
kind of euphoria and instead of trying
to create a new situation good
neighborly partner relations they
started to explore new free geopolitical
spaces while free in their here and
that's why we were witnessing the
expansion of nita eastwards another
phenomena I was always wondering why
that was happening and finally arrived
at a conclusion I thought that some of
our partners were under the illusion
that after the second world were there
used to be one world order and now that
the USSR was gone they thought there was
vacuum which had to be filled and I
think that is not the right approach to
what's finding a solution to these
issues and that's why Iraq
happens we know and our partners agree
that there were errors committed in
abroad but still it happened once again
in Libya and now in Ukraine we are not
the original cause of those crisis
phenomena which are happening in Ukraine
they should not have supported the
illegal coup d'etat anti-constitutional
coup d'etat as well as a forceful
seizure of power which finally resulted
in a serious confrontation in Ukraine
and civil war as it were what has to be
done now today no doubt the agreements
reached in men's the capital of Belarus
should be observed let me emphasize if
we were not content with something we
wouldn't have put our signature there
but we have put our signature and
reverse documents and we will seek their
full implementation I'd like to draw
attention to this fact your attention in
the attention of our partners but we
cannot do that unilaterally and I'm
repeating it over and over again they're
telling us Russia has to influence
somehow the situation in the southeast
part of Ukraine but that is not enough
influence has to be exercised also on
the central authorities in Kiev and we
we cannot do that this is the Avenue
which has to be pursued by our Western
partners the Europeans the United States
let's work together